[Music]
foreign
[Music]
parts of me there was days because it's
a monotonous [ __ ] day you know what
question life you're like am I a [ __ ]
live you know like like did I I you know
like you know [ __ ] like that because I
had no like everybody was gone by then
my grandparents had passed
um you know there was no real connection
to anything that was Jose you know like
little Jose you know like other than my
homies the ones that knew me from as a
kid that were there or they weren't
there and so like I would like question
that you know like I was and then so I
internally I was like churning like like
thinking and thinking and then but I was
also
um intelligent enough to remember like I
said those things that were given to me
those those Blessings by the other gods
you know here is the [ __ ] you know
you know like those [ __ ] God uh Greek
[ __ ] mythologies you know when
homeboy Perseus or whatever gets this
little [ __ ] flute and [ __ ] you know
and then winning you'll know when you
need to use it you know like what the
[ __ ] am I gonna do with it or why
whatever and then the time comes oh [ __ ]
you know yeah like that you know those
little [ __ ] nuggets of wisdom you
know we're starting starting to like pop
up and I remember those and I just think
like oh [ __ ] you know everything like
like again another veil was kind of
dropped you know and you you do you
really credit that to reading I mean do
you really credit that to to to like
sort of expanding your Universe by this
sort of also ever-present thing that is
that is books and literature and and and
and you you see the size of the world
yeah man I remember Frankenstein man and
I just remember words that didn't make
sense until later I remember reading
these books that were you know like over
my [ __ ] Dome when I was reading them
but made sense after you know like the
verses of like like how Mary Shelley
said you know when he quoted that he's
like hey if if I can Inspire love then
I'll [ __ ] create fear you know and
and it's like I didn't get that until
later you know when it's like you can't
if no one wants to love me then [ __ ] it
you know I'm gonna be this [ __ ]
you know or or [ __ ] it I'm gonna be the
person that you want me to be and I'm
gonna be it at the best you know and
then it ain't gone and click until I
[ __ ] like oh [ __ ] you know those
moments of that or or play or verses
from like Lord of the Flies you know
Lord of the Flies is one that I think
about when I first went to High Desert
and my first Riot when we went out and
it was like a small ride I mean you know
we're coming out by fours and by sixes
and then by the time we hit the 10
that's when we strike you know and I was
one of the first ones with my like my
first one was that and was that and I
remember walking up and that guy who was
like dictating to us he was [ __ ] old
in my mind like you [ __ ] all I
remember he's telling that after we're
in the hall you [ __ ] old man he was
23 24. but he was already a veteran you
know in that sense and he was like
telling me like hey you know what this
is this you know when this happens don't
fall man don't [ __ ] fall you know
don't know because then you're [ __ ]
you know and so like he was giving me
these you know these words of wisdom and
then I think of Lord of the Flies man
like [ __ ] dude like I remember that kids
[ __ ] telling other kids dictating how
to you know and violent you know in that
sense and that's what it was you know
and so like that type of [ __ ] started to
float up again like like the alphabet
soup you know the the words that I that
I read the the the count of money
Crystal like things like that or even
[ __ ] Batman you know and so it it I
yeah I attribute that in education you
know to help I'm not saying that that
was a hundred percent because I had
education that wasn't in the [ __ ]
book you know I had education that was
that I earned by [ __ ] trial and error
or that was blessed upon me like I said
by the words of [ __ ] Kronos you know
you know he [ __ ] said these words
into the air that I understood the
language and I didn't understand the
meaning I just knew that what it the
word meant and then when I was over
there I understood what it meant you
know and then that's what I attribute as
far as like
my path towards what I would say what
was said as like Rehabilitation you know
I started to like things were starting
to change and I started to like I [ __ ]
and am I is this it like what the [ __ ]
am I meant to be then if this was all I
meant to be like it's [ __ ] whack you
know like why I'm [ __ ] why you know like
the [ __ ] man
never like nothing else I couldn't have
been a [ __ ] Chef you know or
something else you know little things
like that and then Here Comes
like people like like that guy you know
who was like telling me these things but
I could I wasn't hearing it because I
was hearing it but I wasn't like I
wasn't hearing it you know and then
finally I was hearing it and hearing it
hearing it and hearing it yeah people
like him you know constantly buttnick is
one of the ones that yeah I could say
but he's just constantly constant
constant constant which I feel like
people like that in general know that
you have to be doing that because of the
inconsistency that they are in the
consistency that you are you know it's
like trying to call someone underwater
you know and they're [ __ ] you just
gotta keep doing it to [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that yeah so and
so I felt like that had to do with that
and and my reading manner my my ability
to like think outside of the box before
I even knew about that when I was that
kid reading those [ __ ] books when I
was this kid
reading about Batman but like I like
Batman and I like you know characters
like that but then I realized why I
connected to those type of characters
they were [ __ ] up like me you know
they just had those little things you
know like [ __ ] he had no parents you
know like he [ __ ] grazed in an
institution you know raised by [ __ ] a
surrogate you know had a [ __ ] agenda
you know felt that he was doing was
right which is right but like little
things like that you know I was like oh
[ __ ] I could relate to that Silver
Surfer was one of my favorite too you
know because he was the guy who who gave
his life up to save his home but here he
is in prison elsewhere with people that
dislike him and he feels [ __ ] like an
outcast you know and then I started to
think like [ __ ] you know all this
started to kind of make sense but didn't
make sense because at the end of the day
I had life you know so it's like what's
the [ __ ] is this like another [ __ ]
curse like is this another [ __ ] slap
in the face for me now to know and not
to be [ __ ] right you know come come
face yes with this knowledge and with
this hope when you there's really
nothing there's nothing there you know
so then I felt like looking back I think
it's like I it's not Divine and spirit
like that like divinity or anything it's
just like it was just meant to be you
know I needed to go through these routes
I don't want to say like that because
that kind of minimizes the people who
are out here fighting against you know
incarcerating people in general you know
which which which I believe in to an
extent you know but I also understand
that like for me that was my path you
know and that's the way it went and
that's the way I came to my conclusions
unfortunately I wish it would have been
[ __ ]
14 that I learned this [ __ ] and then 15
I was cool and then you wouldn't you and
I would probably not be talking in this
context maybe in another context you
know and so like
when that happened it was just like kind
of sucked because then I knew and now I
know and it's like [ __ ] man it's like
that pro athlete who's really good but
[ __ ] year old man you you ain't gonna
[ __ ] play in the game so it's like it
it was that but then things started to
change man laws perspectives you know uh
at least I would I at that time what I
heard because I was still in that box
and people like Scott and people like
Elizabeth Calvin were coming in and be
like hey you know people are thinking
different or people are this planning
but but at the same time it's like but
I'm still here you know so
what the [ __ ] does that got to do with
me you know you know but they were like
again they had a uphill bottle in a
different battle now meaning like when
those people started coming your life
and you have sort of like this other
introduction of these new ideas this
this this new sort of approach this this
this possibility this carnal of hope
that's starting to Bubble Up do you
think that somebody else can reach
somebody who's in that state or do they
need to take that first step themselves
to realize it you know there might be
some something more to life it might be
like you had do you have to start to to
at least acknowledge that maybe I want a
little bit more than that in order to be
reached I feel like I'm a proponent for
that because I believe you have to
because
anatic is an addict and they don't see
[ __ ] someone who's Crazy doesn't think
they're [ __ ] crazy right they think
everyone else is tripping on them you
know so it's like you have to have that
moment of like man am I crazy right like
am I am I [ __ ] am I [ __ ] crazy you
know and so like yeah I feel like that
has to be something in there has to
because you have to have a like a like a
contrast for what it is that you're your
normality there has to be a country
that's kind of like giving you the
eyebrow to yourself that's contradicting
what you're living straight up and so
and then from that it's two things could
possibly happen in my limited opinion of
what that could clinically be is that
one you could either eat it up yourself
and like justify it condone it minimize
it and then if no one's around you to
kind of like
stoked the fire of that contradiction or
anything not even a person just anything
it's gonna get [ __ ]
you know assimilated and Justified and
then buried into her the problem would
be to [ __ ] get that person to come
back and look for it in their little
treasure Troy to take time and so for me
it was there and I think I had it
because I was already questioning it and
then little like I said it was kind of
[ __ ] looking back it's kind of like
all kinds of [ __ ] worlds were [ __ ]
coming into being you know like boom
boom boom every path that that I had
everything that was coming into being
laws were changing here I am now having
to go to board and I don't know what the
[ __ ] that was I heard of it but it was
always downplayed oh you're never
getting out so who gives a [ __ ] you know
like Boris bored as whack you know and
so I'm going to board and having these
conversations and they're listening to
me and they're like
you have something in there but you just
raw you know like in that context like
you I see it you know and I think that's
what they saw meaning like I would talk
like I am now
but a little bit more on the other side
you know I was talking and they would be
like this [ __ ] knows what the [ __ ] but
he just doesn't know you know he knows
he's supposed he's walking that way but
he doesn't know that he needs to go that
way like just a little bit to the right
you know he's over here [ __ ] walking
blindly but he knows what he needs to do
I think at least we think he does and
then so that's where I feel like yeah
they started to like try and then now it
was just like like a little kid who just
didn't want to like no no you know like
it's good for you it's good for you just
[ __ ] eat it man he said you know you
eat the food you have to eat right yeah
I don't have to eat I know I have to eat
good food you know that certain foods
are there yeah yeah why not it looks
ugly you know whatever you know so then
they knew that so then from there I felt
like they enabled me and then like I
said the [ __ ] situations with like I
heard this dude talk like what the [ __ ]
you know and then like conversations and
then them coming from the outside my
only true link now to the outside world
and it wasn't like my link to my blood
relatives or to my anything like that
was my connection to Jose you know it
was mostly along the lines like shit's
changing they're looking at it
differently they're seeing that they
[ __ ] up I mean like they shouldn't
send a [ __ ] Miner here you know they
should have at least tried a little
harder you know but here's your chance
you know and like chance for what you
know it's about [ __ ] something you
know it's like they're never gonna let
me out I've never seen anybody go home I
would [ __ ] be that guy you know that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] dude you know [ __ ] thinking
they're gonna drown holding on to a
stick and two feet of water you know and
there's like just stand up stand up no
no no I don't [ __ ] see you know
anybody but nobody's standing up you
know like that type of [ __ ] yeah and
they were like
that's gonna happen you just got it's
you know just then this and that and
then I went to board for the first time
and I remember how
ill prepared I was but kind of prepared
I was playing I always tell this because
I was playing soccer and I heard it I
knew I had to go I had a duck it and I
knew I had to go to [ __ ] uh board but
I didn't give a [ __ ] you know because
every everything around me told me
doesn't matter you know not getting now
this life is life have you seen anybody
in my little [ __ ] dude have you ever
seen anybody go home no
you know like so why are you even
[ __ ] doing that you know so like yeah
yeah you're right you know [ __ ] that you
know so then I was playing hey you gotta
go I'm not gonna do [ __ ] you know it's
like
[ __ ] the fine little kid I ain't
doing [ __ ] you know it's like well
you're gonna go or you're gonna you know
they're gonna take you and it's like
take me like why you know like can I
just deny it it's like no no you gotta
go so I go and I'm like well you know
what I got a shower stipulating [ __ ]
you're like you know looking back I'm
like what the [ __ ] you know but he's
like go ahead just pick it quick you
know [ __ ] shower I walk out to the
gate and the guy was like Hey man the
seal he's like [ __ ] man you know that
and I'm like hey I had to shower and
he's like [ __ ] and he's like where's
your folder you know you know you're
like portfolio I'm like folder what the
[ __ ] you talking about folder and he's
like all right [ __ ] it you know like I
ain't gonna let let's go you know like
yeah like I don't even worry we'll try
yeah so here I am and I go to this
hearing and they sit me down and they
start asking me these questions you know
like this but more intimidating because
you got [ __ ] Commissioners and a
district attorney and you got guards and
it's just like this and you're like this
and you're [ __ ] alone again and
obviously Authority and all this [ __ ]
hey and they're asking hey you do the
first question they asked me I remember
is like do you know what you're in here
for
which is a loaded question because
they're trying to vaguely see what it is
you know yeah I say what do you mean you
know like okay now we're starting like
that okay you know that's where they
were like what do you mean like if I
were to say that what do you mean you
know like Okay okay then they accept the
tone so when they ask me it's like you
know what you're in for I go you mean in
here or in here you know and they're
like yeah you know what you're in here
in prison it's like yeah I Commander
murder and [ __ ] doing time you know
and they're like okay you know and so
you know then they're asking and so I
was answering like that you know like
you know do you know this like yeah man
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens you know and then
they're like
we're gonna have to stop this you know
give us a second you know and they pause
which is something that they really
rarely do which is they stop the hearing
and they took me back to the cage and
then they had my lawyer
and they came and my lawyer came back
and said hey I don't know what the [ __ ]
but they're asking for you to postpone
you know I don't want to [ __ ]
postpone everyone I don't want to do
that [ __ ] because then I had to do it
again right he's like yeah they're
asking to put phone come back in three
years I'm like man [ __ ] that I don't
want to come back no years you know like
I don't want to do this [ __ ] you know
like I don't want to do this man and
he's like they never do that I don't
know why they [ __ ] did that you know
they're just saying hey advise your
[ __ ] client that's what they told me
advise your client to postpone you know
and I was like nah nah nah and I just
remember he was like like
like talking to a [ __ ] kid I would
assume you know like talking to a kid
who's just like you you need to eat you
know like I'm not gonna eat [ __ ] you
know like just like that and finally he
was like you know what [ __ ] it do
whatever the [ __ ] you want he told me
and I'm like oh you know what I guess
I'll postpone he's like you [ __ ]
man like why you [ __ ] made me do that
I was like whoa you're getting all bent
out of shape man so I feel like [ __ ] if
you're pissed it has nothing to do with
you then there must be something some
reason why because you're really [ __ ]
you're red you know he's a white dude
and he's like you're [ __ ] red you
know I told him that he's like you're
mad you know and he's like [ __ ] man you
know he took me back and they taught and
they were like Jose so it's our us you
know it's brought to our attention that
you want to postpone correct
and on loud and we're like yeah yeah
sure he's like okay we're gonna post
this here you know you know the whole
formalities okay cut the tape you know
because they're recording all this and
they're like
say you understand that you know had you
gone on with this hearing we're gonna
deny you for at least 15 years
[Music]